All right.
Hello. Welcome, everyone.
It is active live stream number 47.1
on August 10th, 2022.
And we're continuing our explorations
into the paper dyad inactive dynamics,
social cognition and Active Inference
of Hippolyta and Venice
and Active Inference
and Abduction by Pierre Tanin and Bene.
Welcome to the Active Institute.
We're a participatory lab,
an institute that is communicating,
learning and practicing
applied active inference.
Links are on the slide.
This is recorded
in an archived livestream,
so please provide us with feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome
and we'll be following video
etiquette for livestreams.
Head over to active inference storage
to learn more about other projects
at the Institute and how to participate
and join learning groups.
Today in extreme 47.1,
we're continuing to learn and discuss
this pair of papers mentioned earlier
and on a previous video,
and we're going to
open with some introductions
and then probably just jump in wherever
anyone has a new question
they'd like to ask.
Maybe ending the introductions with Blue
so that you can bring
a new vector into the conversation.
So I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California,
and I'm looking forward to
taking a one lens
a little bit to the paper, which had
an extended dot zero as there is so much
to learn on a few of these angles
and so much to kind of
think about that.
What is the difference between
being in the bathtub
and then in the middle
of the paper pair versus, for example,
coming into it to contextualize it
or trying to leave it to apply it.
Something in between, even there.
I'll pass it to Dean.
Thanks, Dean.
I'm here in Calgary.
I don't know if I don't know
what the DOT one needs
because we've never done a dot
one where we've tried to pull two things
but the proximal and see what happens
because sometimes that's fire and water
and just to get a lot of steam
and sometimes it's nature on glycerin
and the whole thing blows up on it.
So I'm kind of looking forward to that.
That's kind of the risky part
that I think is kind of exciting.
I'll pass it over to student.
Oh, thanks.
Dean Yeah, it's Stephen here in Toronto.
I'm really curious around
what this infusion
of two different approaches
to active movements can yield.
So what's behind it or what's behind
an approach of an activism
that brings in instrumental
is an approach that's more mathematically
focused, bringing in realism.
So I'm curious and hopefully it's
going to be useful and practical.
I'm going to pass over to
but. I am blue, I'm in New Mexico.
I really enjoyed reading.
So I've read the I think we did the hip
Alito paper before on another live stream
and as I've read that one before,
but I really enjoyed reading this
abduction and active in French paper.
I do not have like a strong
philosophy background,
so I kind of come at this like with
what is this?
But is that like,
I have to go search Wikipedia
100 million times
to kind of get more information about.
So from a philosophical aspect.
And so one of the key things like where
I was having a hard time, like locking in
on this abduction paper active
in France and abduction is
why do first in blankets
like like they presented
the authors presented it as if the first
like it's like necessitate
a realist perspective.
So so is that true?
And if so, why is that?
All right.
Thanks, everyone.
So two threads blew in what I heard
and I think two areas for us to kind of
get on the slide
and see at the same time.
So one was like different approaches
that can be taken both by an individual,
like different backgrounds in different
fields or disciplines, and then kind of
going beyond one person's just learning
trajectory and thinking, what are the
conceptual approaches that we can take
to, in this case, active inference.
But this might be studying
active inference
and applying acting inference
kind of both ways might come into play.
And then the question of the first
and blankets,
something like what aspects of what
enable
a situational realist
or a instrumentalist?
Just why are people taking
the stances they're taking
on a given situation
sometimes even like mixed across
different contexts
for the same system, they might use one
or another or something like that.
Steven
And this brings action
back into the equation.
I sense that action is quite important
because the idea of instrumentalist
in a way is there's a use of
certain instruments.
And that's that's the best way to think
of what's happening with the blankets.
Actually, I think it's really cool
that you brought the blankets up because
that question
comes in and it activates like
the temptation
is to make everything realist.
And then it's like, okay,
we got a blanket.
So it's kind of like, well, maybe
we should make sure we keep the blanket
question in an instrumental way
to avoid all those traps.
And then on the other side, it's
like on the math side, it's like, well,
these tension funded mental
dynamics
well, as they're being acted in some way,
they must have some relation to reality
in some way.
So it's sort of almost the mirror
is not the mirror, but it's something
that's sitting on the other side
in an interesting way.
I don't know what Dana thinks
in that point, but.
I was going to mention that I,
I think if we are taking two papers
and actually
doing a bit of what happens
when they get entangled,
then we're looking at what happens
when something is actively inferred
as a process as opposed to active
inference as a subject matter or topic.
And so when we do that,
we're essentially asking
the big questions
on one of the next slide here is
so is active inference both as process,
as actively inferring and of process,
something falls out of that.
And we, we asked it in the, in the using
metaphor of being both a gripper.
Right.
Something as process thing
and a process being gripped.
And so
yeah, I think if we, if we,
if we actually look at it as what's,
what's going on,
not just from the doing sense,
but from the observing sense
or participatory sense,
I think it leaves us with no choice
but to say that there's got to be
some going back and forth between both.
But that's just my take.
So let me let me read this
quote from the paper specifically
going back to to the blanket,
the one that set off my, my, my question.
But that's like unanswered.
If says
okay, according
to recent interpretations of the FP,
the dynamical interaction
of living systems and the external world
under active inference can be interpreted
semantically.
This is a Ramstad 2020 citation
by assuming
that sensory states are meaningful
representations of the reality.
This is especially the case if we assume
that the development of Markov blankets
by Friston,
unlike their original characterization
and works of Judea Pearl
on probabilistic causal networks, admit
a realist interpretation
of the relationship
between the organism and the environment.
So it says,
while the role of the concepts of Markov
blankets and Perl blankets
in many treatments of the free energy
principle is an instrumentalist
one or as in Pearson's even stronger
terms, concede to a nominal list
interpretation of their meaning.
Fashion blankets are realist
not only in the non instrumentalist
sense, but also in the sense of being non
nominal list entities.
The modal terms of references to real
possibilities such as what is conceivable
or produced by imagination
or anticipatory li related to the future.
States of affairs are used in making
sense of the key aspects of the theory
and so
in my recollection
the first didn't think it like I didn't
have that linked to realism necessarily
per say.
So Daniel like maybe Kant,
do you have any more clarification?
Like, is that like a realist?
A blanket is a realist
interpretation of the blanket
or or am I just forgetting that?
But I read that part.
I didn't know what Nominalism was.
So according to the summary,
the view that Universals and abstract
objects do not actually exist
other than being merely
names or labels.
One version denies
the existence of universals,
the other the abstract.
So it's an anti generalist position.
So let's see where that was used
with the first and blanket,
because this is the
crux of the discussion.
Like one of the frontiers of contact
other than just saying, well,
and activism and dynamical systems
theory work like this coarsely
or this broad area
math and chemistry work
together like this.
This is starting to get into
the real contact points of
turf semantically that are being vied
over.
People have different perspectives
on how to interpret
base graphs in different contexts.
And so then the mark of blanket is like
it still might even be too coarse grains
to for that whole turf
to be controlled by one view or another.
So then
let's look at how
the abduction paper
and anything else that you see,
where would it be more justified,
just in your sense?
Well, and then we'll unpack this,
because I think this was just copied in
to discussed today,
since it's obviously a clear area
where both papers are talking
about their view on the mark of Blanket,
which might make it clearer
to see how multiple views on
blankets and graphs
come into play.
But let's unpack
both of their perspectives.
Saying the nominal list
interpretation and as as you're unpacking
that, it's something
I didn't have to look up because it's
a very prominent theme in Buddhism.
Right.
Like, like that, you know,
it's like the absence
of any kind of inherent existence.
Like said, that existence is nominal.
And so it's interesting
that in this abduction paper
that they take this this,
you know, construction
by Peirce of Nominalism.
But but also,
like more than once in that paper,
they point to an objective reality,
which is like if
if things are interpreted, interpreted,
if all stuff is
nominally interpreted, then
what is the subjective reality
other than like linguistics
or semantics or perhaps semiotics?
Yeah.
So even
that's a very good point
because it also ties back to you
mentioned about when we're talking
about the relationship
almost being the reality,
I sense that they were kind of saying
if there's a relationship,
those relational dynamics,
I didn't use the word dynamics, therefore
have some
it's can be called real, you know,
which I think is a fair assertion
in some senses,
although, you know, again,
that could be an overextension
because there's a question about
how much you go into transcendental
and how much you go down
into the kind of more morphology
and the whole morphogenesis.
And there's actually a really good
there's a
actual La-Z-Boy is actually
it does a lot of work
with search of the oppressed
and work with
people
who've been tortured and stuff like that.
And he talks about
the medicine is in the wounds,
the medicine is in the wounds
when people get no
coma, etc..
And one of the things that's interesting
there is that
we may be in a culture,
there's times
when we might try to explain things or
do transcendental work
to to transcend a situation or avoid us.
And we may actually avoid the situation.
But sometimes when you go into the wound,
what you might find
is is literally a bloody mess.
So that may not be real
in the normal sense.
Then let's start out a little bit.
I think it's interesting that most
representations of Markoff, I could show
the markup blanket in between
to two distinct
sets of properties
and that's always represented
on the horizontal.
And I think what's interesting here
is that if
if you exactly if you find yourself
in a in a debate situation
of two top down perspectives,
one that says
it must be from the top down and active
or it must be from the
top down some some series of
some series or
set of different logics
apply depending upon your familiarity
with what it is that you're observing,
that can lead
to that whole question of
hierarchy,
and then what entails the other.
So for me, it's pretty
it's pretty easy to understand why
people who take the exclusive position of
instrumental ism
as entailing
something like logic
or the other hierarchical relations
chip of the logic being the real thing,
and then the actions to follow, or
that's the thing that's being entailed.
I think what the diagrams,
what a lot of the pictures tell us
is that there's
a lateral aspect to this as well.
And so if we're going to look at that
lateral less
which which is enveloping
the other top down view
because both of the views
in both of these papers,
if the bias or the
the position that the authors take
is one of top
down, what what rules under
this set of conditions or circumstances,
placing those two things side
by each strips away
some of the questions around relativity
and now introduces
the idea of around relationship,
but not relationship
in terms of power over
but relationship in terms
of what needs to be present in order
for somebody to be able
to actually make fewer prediction errors.
So the mark up blanket,
I think can be turned.
I mean, right now, most of it is
is perceived as being some sort
of a vertical partition between
lateral elements.
I mean, it can be flipped.
And we've talked often in lots of papers
about what's the hierarchical structure,
what's the bottom
up, what's the top down.
But I think both of these papers
admittedly say we are taking a top down
view of this
and therefore
they are constraining themselves
to more
emphasis on the relativity aspect of
what is going on in in it
in an actively inferring way.
Then they are looking at it
as a relationship between the sensing
and the act.
Right? Well, a lot of stuff.
Let's go through the abduction.
Markoff blanket discussion.
The first part is
the statement of context,
potentially
for a philosophical background.
But it's important
that they're placing this
along
the lines of other places in biology.
So these are systems
that are self perpetuating
in a diffusive multi-scale self
way perhaps, but they're self creating.
We're not just taking them as existing
in a certain contrived arrangement.
5 minutes ago
we're thinking about systems that have
maintained a non equilibrium
steady state with their environments
and if not the end.
If someone denies
the realism or the anything
of the
environment, then that
can be verbalized and even cognizant.
But it is not enacted
by persistent systems either.
From the view from the inside
or like if one
just stops breathing or something
like that, or the view from the outside.
Because again, systems with persistent
measurements have to be at least
doing well enough to persist amidst
the regularities, the environment.
So this is kind of like grounding it
in an evolutionary
and developmental framework,
but connecting it to the non-equilibrium
steady state maintenance,
which is grounding this realism
discussion in a relationship
with the environments,
not as like in a priori.
Then there's a definition of Markoff
blanket
the blanket state
conditional independence
between notes in a base graph,
which doesn't mean
that influence doesn't travel
or that those states
aren't semantically about each other,
but it means that they're conditionally
independent in a statistical way.
External states
in supposed I'm not sure this author,
but the end of Semiotic View
would be like potentially meaning
on the inside.
Like photons on the retina
really are light.
It really is the case
that that's the real thing
within that facet of biological function
and internal states
describe from exo's semiotic perspective.
So perhaps like the interpretive view,
so a view from the inside,
the true influence of a of a feature,
and the kind of studying of a view
from the outside where those agree.
You have some meiosis
like with a stop sign
and it means stop in the situation
with different entities.
This speaks directly to active inference
given that the regulation
of the entropy of the internal state.
So all these functions
that we're describing
as being like bounded
or constrained or minimized
or having to do with that interfaces
surprise control on action, outgoing
and then bounded, surprise on perception,
which is also very force age
by like the perceptual control
theory and various motor theories
which we've talked about,
but like the reflex arc
challenging the way that people
models decision making, for example.
Then in many
treatments they're agreeing that people
take an instrumentalist usage or stance
first, and blankets are released
not only in the non instrumentalist
sense, opens up
a whole discussion with non and anti,
but also in the sense of being non
non ist entities.
And then in this last quote,
it would be great to hear more
from the authors about what
the modal terms of reference are.
But the part that stands out here
is the real possibilities,
because for these systems,
with these features engaging in this way,
their cognition can be considered real
to the extent
it has all of these features
and is tied to the environment over time
and so on.
Hope that is one view on it
because many paragraphs in the abducted
paper and an inactive paper,
if you
really engage with their structured
arguments, there's
some much to like read in between and
to respect the way that they've laid
out the argument,
while also hopefully now all
seeing interesting ways to connect it.
So Stephen and then anyone else?
Yeah, this is a little bit
so feeding back to you, Daniel.
So in case
you've got a thought on this one, because
the, you know, there's the,
there's the, the biological aspect here
that you bring it up.
And I agree with that.
And, you know, in the work on the brain
just has been talking about
moving from, say, a causal correlation
to a functional correlation.
And there can be many ways of
getting somewhere when it's functional.
So then, right, of course, in this case,
there's a certain element of
what's
real in
terms of what we scientifically is.
It's scientific realism.
As a scientist, what is real in
what's being scientifically deducted.
So if it's been deductive,
it is a perspective that's being taken.
So within the perspective
that's been taken on a certain
state, it's not equal of Librium
steady states.
Where is that
regime of attention,
the scientific regime
at attention,
purely an instrument to be considered?
Or is it for the things it's analyzing
that could be real.
So there could be so the get out clause
yet they could still be phenomenon
rather than perspectives and logic
sitting underneath
that which have many dynamics
to get to the same outcome.
So what's your thoughts on that then?
My thought is I want to hear
what Blue and Dean would say on it.
Okay, come.
Yeah, Steve first.
Go ahead, go ahead.
Loop each. You.
Know, go for it then.
I want to hear what you have to say.
Okay.
Well, what I hear here's
an interesting thing about both papers
and maybe,
maybe the authors of the papers
will push back hard on this, but that's
what I'm used to.
Both papers take a scientific perspective
on this,
very much a scientific perspective,
which in my books is easily
as an idiom, is when I see it,
I'll believe it.
They want the evidence, right?
They want it.
They want that sort of inductive,
deductive piece
to sort of sit front and set.
They want proof, which is great,
I get that.
But what I think
is really fascinating about this is while
they are holding up
that that epistemic priority,
they're also talking a lot about,
I'll invert that.
And they say I'll believe it
when I see it.
So there's a lot of faith in this.
It hasn't materialized yet,
but if I continue to exist
in a social setting or as an agent,
yes. What I've got to have faith
that all this time
that keeps rolling
out, I'm going to continue
for whatever
purposes, goals or directives
I'm taking to work through
the not seeing it until I actually
arrive at that moment
where something materializes,
when I can say,
Oh, now I have the evidence.
So there's are both papers.
Have a real
they play they play with themselves.
They dance with themselves
in the sense that they are both papers
from an exclusive standpoint saying we
we are looking at this scientifically
and mathematically.
And yet in order
for us to be able to hold on to this
this this, this thought
or idea of the ATP
being, you know, I'm
I'm I'm whatever it's called,
steady state.
I've just lost the expression.
Non-Equilibrium Thank you.
Non-Equilibrium steady state.
I do have to believe in something
in order for whatever
materialization, goal or outcome I'm
I'm moving towards it.
That's almost Oasis or Alice Thesis
or I want a sandwich 5 minutes from now.
I have to believe in that thing
or my agency
or my ability to achieve or attain
before I can actually have that thing.
So from from from that alone,
I find it really interesting
that there's a certain amount of naivete
in both papers.
There's a kind of a we have to
keep our hat to this rookie view
that every time we realize something,
there has to be a little bit of faith
or a little bit of belief
in what's going on.
Those priors actually
exist, and I'm going to use them
because I want to carry out
whatever my priorities are.
And it doesn't matter whether it's the
top down newness of abduction and logic
or the top down units of an activism,
they both tip their hat to the bottom.
Happiness of I got to kind of have a
I got to kind of have a confidence that
so that even if it's not here now,
at some point it will either continue
the way I want it to or whatever change
I want to impose on it.
I have that capacity to wait it out
and have that thing happen.
So yeah, that's what I would add
to what Steven was saying.
Luke Yes. So.
So I'll say a couple of things
that I
was looking at just now, the difference
between a Christian
like what is a Christian blanket?
And I came across a paper
that we're going to have to discuss.
It's called Scientific Realism
about Christian Blankets
Without Literalism,
and it's by Christine and Kirchhoff.
So someday we're going to have to have
that.
It's a preprint
up on philosophical archives now.
So so apparently like having a real
boundary can be like literal.
Like there's like
a literal interpretation
or a realist interpretation.
And so just like I'm
still trying to narrow down
like what is this realist interpretation
of a Christian blanket?
And yeah, so in also a very real sense
like what is the real boundary
of a living thing?
Like I don't,
I can't find my real boundary.
Like, where do I stop?
And something else begins.
There are like hundreds and trillions.
I don't even know
more non human cells in my body
than there are human cells like.
So I always have to come back to this.
So what would I be
without all of those non-human things?
Are those non-human things also me like
but then like, you know, I'm constantly
like ingesting new ones
and excreting old ones and so like,
and they're coming into my skin
and leaving my skin.
So where is my boundary?
Like, do I have to have this boundary
in order for active inference
and like the Markoff
blanket interpretation to apply?
I don't know that that's
necessarily true.
So like I could just get off of it.
I love this paper and I love
like the semiotic interpretation
in like the objective sense.
Like, but does it even really matter?
Like like
so the realist interpretation,
like to someone who doesn't believe
in like a shared
objective reality is never going to work.
Or like, can you find the boundary?
Like where is this line
between self and other or like between
like like I can't find the boundary.
So like for me
it's all a modeling perspective
that doesn't lessen
the impact of this abduction
as active inference paper for me at all.
Like I really thought
it was a great paper and has a lot of
really cool things
to say about cognition and perception.
So like,
why are we hung up on this still?
I don't know. Or
both of you
go for it and then I'll add some notes.
Could I just add one more note? Yep.
I mean, I think look, I agree
with totally with Dean on this
this bottom up phenomenon.
You know, that's that's going to be there
in the background.
Maybe it's always going to be unknowable,
apart from some of these simulations
giving us insights.
But I think also what Blue is saying
there is for me
this whole boundary question
is where is the problem with a systems
discussion in terms of that
being kind of naturalized?
And I think that it
because you end up with
because systems are defined that way,
what's inside, what's outside.
And for me, the big revelation
and I think for a lot of people,
maybe in the biological sciences,
it's not so unusual to think this way,
but to think about agent based modeling,
to think about where where's the agent,
where's the agency, the teleology.
And that
agency
doesn't necessarily sit on a boundary
in the same way that systems tend to.
I mean, someone could argue
that it doesn't have to,
and I'm sure it doesn't,
but it ends in many ways ends up there.
Right. In reality, in terms of discourse.
So, you know,
we want that discourse to be clear.
We're doing this work with systems
engineering to have it
where we want these clear divisions
for the purpose of ontological discourse.
So we know what we're talking about
and why, however, which is where
maybe there's a challenge
this agent agency,
teleology, gee, morphological
dynamics are something else than that.
And I'll pass that to Daniel and maybe
his answer will come in somewhere.
I'm not sure. Yeah, Dean first.
Then I'll go for it.
I'll be real quick here.
So in some of the diagrams,
I know that, Daniel, you're you're
you're really good at this.
Some of the diagrams,
the markup, like it is literally a
an oval with the word discrepancy in it.
And so all I would to to
to add on to what you were saying is that
if you want a hard physical boundary
and you want to discover what that is,
I think you're looking at it again.
What where is this?
Where is does one thing and and another
thing start as a relativity question?
What I'm suggesting is if you're looking
at the bottom up and the top down
as a relationship,
not as which is which is more powerful
or holds more influence over the other,
you're looking at that as a relationship.
And it's that relationship holds
as a discrepancy zone.
It's not necessarily something
that has the physical beginning and end.
It's kind of it kind of fluid.
And it and it's it's not to say
we shouldn't
look at the relativity at all.
It is to say, let's have one eye
on the relativity piece.
And the other eye on the relationship
is the discrepancy
between it doesn't
it doesn't lend itself to hard stops.
It's discrepancy if that's all that is.
That's just what it is.
It means we're not sure about anything
other than the difference.
We don't know where
where the separation boundary is.
But that's kind of where this rule.
Let's bring these two papers
together thing came from, because
if we're actively inferring,
we can bound around that discrepancy.
It doesn't always have to be a partition.
That's
what the that's what the importance is.
You're potentially
if we can have two things
being held simultaneously or
co-occurrence.
All right. Wow. Well, well blocked there.
Well, first one, the discrepancies
textbook figure to three, discrepancy.
Not a blanket or discrepancy
as blanket of blanket, etc..
And that can be a continuous
or discrete value.
But in non idealized
like non
singular path of least action settings
a.k.a real
settings,
there's always a non-zero value.
So that's one way to leave the door,
always a little open
in a way that just having to feed on zero
or one or any rapid
switching strategies of zeros and ones
doesn't really capture
that in the same way then.
BLUM Great question.
Like we asked a little bit
about at the beginning, why?
What is leading someone to consider
something
like a blanket in a realist
or an instrumentalist light
and pointed to factors
like the persistence of the organism
and the reality of like the action
inflow with its environments.
So it kind of forces
somebody to say, well,
if the environment is real,
then the entity and the actions and the
meiosis of their actions are real.
If stop signs are real
and stopping at a stop sign is real
and they're all part of the
non-equilibrium steady state,
what, what
further realism does one want to know
then that
there is a territory and then this is
the maps of the territory.
So some are going to go all the way
into territory skepticism
or how will they
then reframe their stance
then on the
just a few other random pieces,
this was in Live Stream three
when we read about communication
and active inference.
And they are,
which is a lot of in the social
and action setting
that we're bringing this objective
light to the social and active setting
that's really like
expounded upon in the Polito
and van ass paper that that goes
into a lot of the scientific
and philosophical aspects of social.
So here they're borrowing
from the framework
of Tinbergen for questions
and providing multiple scales of analysis
that are all like the four whys.
And these four Ys are kind of
like a two by two quadrant.
And so then that allows in biology
parallel of research agendas
and integration
because like the fact that brain regions
are connected to each other up
here on the mechanism side
is part of the picture, but it's a yes.
And with the pattern of DNA
divergence times
like you could imagine situations
where they're correlated or not
and they could be causing it or not,
and it could be either way of causation
or a confounding factor
or any other number of things.
And then neither of those have a direct
closed door
on like what the birdsong sounds like.
So without even going into
what the birdsong is like, interpreted
as there still is space within that
interpretive
or semiotic scientific approach,
that is
hopefully as we can explore,
considering
the research in that application
in a different way
than it's been partitioned
in certain
specific analyzes in the past, then
well.
So I'll, I'll throw something out there
knowing that
I had not really thought about it more
than while I was listening to you talk.
So if it's completely wrong, somebody
can can correct me really quickly.
I think it's really interesting
that both of these papers
provide
what I would consider to be a stable
or a stabilizing effect
on what we might describe
as something resembling strategy
for the potential for strategy.
What I'm always thinking about is
that strategy is not behavior behaviors.
Usually, given the label tactics,
but that strategy does
include the anticipation and the logic
that is applied.
And I think that's
where we're not in conflict.
When we say there's a triadic
and there's a code construction
of the social scene,
because I think both of those things
provide the still stability
or the platform then to strategize
and minimize those prediction errors.
So again, we can still
we can still build off of strategy and do
and we can still build off of strategy
and eliminate
constant, bad, consequential decisions.
So, again,
that's the relationship as as opposed
to which one of these two approaches,
these two top down approaches
is the
is the thing that holds the most sway,
because at any given time, well, one
or the other are both.
As long as you don't get trapped in one
would actually be the most
I would think would be the most option
generating, not option.
So I think as you talk in the adduction
paper about the different types
of abduction, what they do
handle,
they emphasize all of that in the end,
both of those types, the generating
and the selecting are essentially
you can't
you can't have one without the other.
So that's an interesting thing
to incorporate here as well,
or at least considered.
I'm not saying you have to take it up,
but if you did,
what would that look like.
Or just directly respond to a few pieces
there, then Steven and then anyone else.
So very interesting connection
with Multiscale
prediction error
or free energy minimization uncertainty
reduction surprises
abounding in Multi-Scale systems.
And then in this social and active
setting that Hippolyta
and Vance brought to the forefront,
that is our gripper and grips
in a way that a little
experiment
on a fixed mirror, active inferences item
or a system described
by any of the conventional mechanics,
classical physics, mechanics, statistical
thermodynamics, quantum
you're kind of
just going off on a prelude
to upcoming discussions with Dalton,
but I think that will pull out an aspect
which is that the Bayesian mechanics
broadens that discussion into
the cognitive dynamics
of active particles.
And so in that way,
a ball following becomes
like a special case of active particles
falling
that could take various paths
based upon their embodied affordances,
even if just described as,
if like the baseballs
not following the parabola equation,
but that's how the real environment
and active particle interact,
which is to say some melodically,
which is why they both
papers
mention abduction in the social context.
And then you mentioned
like these two top down perspectives
and how when we have the divergence
between among like multi
three body problem, we have multiple
ideas, minimum of two, hopefully more.
And then there are strange attractors.
There's, there's Lifestream
32, there's life from 26.
Everything happens in that space
from the top down
because there's always going to be
a plurality from the bottom up.
So the one error that wouldn't
just be the right course
training for sure is a singular
I of more laser.
And that leads to basically
the unexpected,
unexpected
with the reality of the bottom up.
And then
when there's divergence is in continuous
state spaces
and paths in between top down,
then there's a bi
directional relationship
with the top down in the bottom up
or the inside out in the outside in,
because you could even move
among those without feeling
like we were like violating a system
to sometimes
use a left to write for time,
or then we could use right
to left for time.
And so seeing those kinds of
cognitive moves as accessible
in a social setting
and then taking that course.
Lastly to
you said that
the two stroke engine of abduction
with the generating and selecting
because the laser is not on the generator
and that's the about
the analogy of attention
in a top down system
like we've seen models and mental action
several times.
Stephen Yeah, thanks Daniel.
You would,
you really go back to that four
by four that you had there
with the ultimate yeah.
And I think that this is really important
because there's also this
implicit enlightenment
assumption
that was always sitting in the background
where up is good.
And I think it's really interesting that
and I think you're absolutely right,
we talk about it talks about ultimate.
So I think it's really curious
and it talks about
we talk about this interactions
is this kind of interaction.
This is the ultimate set of interactions,
the robin and that is what the truth is
seen as what's the rational truth
when we go up and we get enlightened.
So then we can project down on
what's there and the idea of that,
what's coming up is interaction.
So that's the general way it's thought.
And there was this
magic box called Emergence
to sort of get around the fact
that really we didn't know.
But I would I would challenge that
not not to say that
that's not true
in terms of how it's perceived, but
there's another way
that bottom up can be explored,
and that is another way
that truth can be explored.
This is rational truth
and this
which I thought ultimate is quite
I get the sense that that is very much
looking out as this
is built into those words. Right.
This assumption that of of enlightenment.
But there's also intimate truth.
Intimate truth
is different to rational truth.
And intimate truth
is not about interactions.
It's about knowing.
It's about a deeper kind of knowing.
So when I go down, it's
not what's coming up in a bottom up.
It's, What am I going?
Well, my only way to engage
it is to go down into it.
Does that make sense?
And that going down into
it is also valuable.
Is no more primitive than enlightenment.
And I think that
that that goes to sort
of the very foundation of the assumption,
which we don't even notice.
It's there about science that everything
is trying to be enlightened.
But that is only partially true.
And I think biology sort of knows that.
But maybe can't speak to it.
That's that's my little piece that.
To try to connect that one layer
closer to,
I think, some academic traditions,
but by no mean a
normed ones.
But thanks, everybody, for sharing those.
It reminds me of the direction taken
in the one of the biographies
I'll paste in the title here.
This is Evelyn Fox Keller's
biography of Barbara McClintock
and the title is A Feeling
for the Organism,
and that
takes a history
and philosophy of science informed view.
Like What is the feeling
for the organism?
How does one have a feeling
for the chromosomes like this?
Belief that there were jumping genes from
certain psychological observations?
And then how does that really play out
when somebody is in a context
of professionalism and like expectations
around different
people who look different and so on?
So that takes a holistic look.
And I think there is that on
every or
many cases that kind of story to tell.
And so that is one bridge of connection.
Blue from like the evolution standpoint.
And I think like part of the question
that Steven asked earlier, like,
can we take multiple trajectories,
be it like top down, bottom
up to arrive at the same conclusion
or the same like end point?
And this is something like in evolution,
there is like convergent evolution
where, you know, completely different
genetically unrelated species
will arrive at the same trait or develop
a very similar appearance that makes
people think like, you know, before
we had DNA relationships like we would
we had species lumped together
because of their similar appearance
that we're actually completely
like unrelated, like we're very distant
on the phylogenetic scale.
So like it's an adaptation
that we converge on the same feature
or we converge to the same argument
or the same like place
in some kind of space.
And this is something that I think
about a lot and just going to like the
the quantum perspective, like can we
you know, all go from,
you know, point A to point Z,
like traversing a different trajectory.
But like if everything is time reversal,
then that's not really possible.
Like we can't converge to the same point.
Like we have to follow a specific path
if time reversibility holds true.
So I had to just like,
throw that in there.
Interesting note.
Let's kind of return to
some of our earlier
frameworks, but
fun stuff, I guess
we knew
we wanted to cover the mark and blanket.
We have explored some of the threads
that justify
the realest or even further stance,
though we still have a lot of questions
for the last 20 minutes or whatever
about like what leads somebody
and what the implications
are for being different stances, causes
and consequences of different stances.
Why does that matter in general?
Studying crystallography?
Why does that matter
for the social setting like decision
making in governance or organization?
That was a justification broadly
for abductions capacity
to be compatible with active inference
and form type
of probably valuable relationship.
Both directions
because active inference gains.
These cognitive features
that were described
before these graphs were invented
analogous to kind of Blue's suggestion
that there was classifications
that were some were really insightful,
others were false competitors
or lump beings or whatever.
Before there was a way
to look at it differently.
That is some
of what grounds a realist interpretation.
So again, we're still not fully closed on
what it means to be realists
or what matters.
But now let's go to the Mark Blanket
in action concept and similarly
break down their angle on the blanket
and understand maybe what leads them
and what their suggested implications
are for that stance.
What kind of a person do they think
they're being by taking this cognitive
social position, which could be asking
both papers and all speech action
and then
where's the beef?
Then what is the
what is the between there?
So anyone can go for it.
What is something to bring in about
an action blankets
and or how everything
is brought together
in Hippolyta and then us 21
just go take your time.
So one of the things that I really like
about this paper is, again, it's
the time it takes
and that that they heavily emphasize
that as part of this code construction
that that enables people
to gain some sense
of what it means to be in a now
social situation.
In fact, they they talk about that.
I'm not sure where it is in the paper,
but they talk about the fact
that people that are that are
new to a cultural setting,
it requires of them
some time in order
for them to be able to pick up on the non
linguistic, nonverbal, non
expressed information that's being passed
within that social realm
and that they're not picking up on. So,
so what, what enables that and that's
when they spend little bit of time
sort of talking out
why that could only be then considered
a co construction
the more you do within that condition,
the more you pick up,
you can't simply be watching.
You can't.
It's in fact,
the transition is going from spectator
to the actual doer.
And so that's that's a heavy
that's a heavy burden
to put on the statistics actual
landscape as you don't sort of
sit there and go, okay,
so what's the probability
that this person who
I can't really understand
because I don't what
link don't even know what they're saying
because they're speaking
a different language.
What's the problem?
A bit like you don't sit there
and kind of do those kind of calculations
or maybe you do,
which is just not aware of it, and you're
not spending a whole lot of time
with your calculator out
trying to figure out what the what
the distribution is.
While you are trying to co construct
or co coordinate your
your active involvement in this new thing
that you're now trying to be a part of.
So that's one of the arguments
that I really like about their paper.
They basically say, in order for this
to work, first thing
we have to appreciate
is that there is a temporal commitment
to making anything happen going forward.
You could if you don't have that
temporal commitment, if you check out
before you've even checked in,
nothing changes, nothing happens.
So from a markup blanket standpoint,
that that essentially goes back
to the discrepancy question.
Is it is it is it a hard boundary?
Well, you can perceive it that way.
There's this limitation now,
because I don't speak their language
or you can look at it is now what is this
what is this evolving discrepancy
and how does it change?
How does it shift?
How does it do deviate
and then re conform, eventually
oscillating down
to some sort of agreement?
That is the instrumental piece.
I'm just saying most people aren't
sitting there calculating
that out as it's as it's happening.
They're basically just trying
to figure out what it's all aiming.
Live want to bring in anything on
and action blankets instrumental ism
and then we can
after that
look at what the inactive writers say.
Think it's been says like in the
in the in activists and instrumentalist
blanket perspective I don't know
that's always tends to be like
the classic way that I think about it
but let's let's see what the authors say.
All right.
Let's see in the first half
how they set up this question
and then we'll end with a fork
in the road that we can discuss.
All right.
So they start
with similarly defining blanket.
We we could look at the word overlap
in the future, but it's scale three tool.
Don't know if Scale Free
was said in the other situation.
It's introduced as a statistical tool
that allows us to interpret
and then again
we see allow for interpreting.
So the language has already conveyed
certain
flexibilities
if one is to take a charitable
though narrow reading.
So this isn't the only way to read,
but just in terms of how
below
the surface an argument is framed as an
as in addition to the direct rhetoric
immediately moving to the relationship
with the physical boundary
in the abducting case,
we saw highlighting of the reality
of the closure of the action
and influence loop.
But there wasn't a justification
of a physical boundary.
And so I do think it is interesting
the earlier discussion
with like how does the multi-agent
or like agent based model perspective
as a scientific tool help us model
blurry systems as like
swarms that are a certain resolution
or density away,
then going straight to the first
in variant of the Markoff blanket where
there are already active and sensory
states rather than introducing it first.
In the general case like that, it's about
statistical insulating sets that can
then under perhaps some situations
be partitioned to like an incoming
representing sense and then an outgoing
representing action aspect.
And so those are the blanket states
sense and action as in a here
and then be in there.
Figure one is the box around S and A
and then the ether and the MMU.
They're like
kind of like flips of each other.
I don't think that's the only reason why
they're those letters
and they don't have to be those letters.
None of them actually
have to be those letters.
But this is the connectedness, structure
or sparsity of what
both the authors are describing.
All right, then here's the fourth.
It is possible to understand
active in Frozen two ways.
I think we each had a few ways
of just today,
a real few
that the properties of the models
should be expected to exist
as an ontological property
in ontological being like
not in the use
of using the active inference ontology
importantly differently enough,
but rather describing
the philosophical, ontological
or real basis.
That's why it's associated with realism.
Then the second way is the non
realist view that the model is simply
an instrumental tool.
So we're at the fork of these two
directions.
What is the moved in.
My my sense the move is that so
what does that not make up a whole
and I'm not saying that in the title
logical sense
I'm saying if we're actively inferring
as opposed to looking at a topic
that's titled active inference, don't
we want to incorporate the entirety,
the complexity or for the sake of
for the sake of being able to
to understand
an action is is active
inference kind of is it a
my question would be
how is active inference actually
being used in each of these papers?
Is it is it is it
is it found in the argument
that we don't want to
get completely complacent
around theory to other minds,
or is it sitting on top of that
kind of the ice and kind of the way
it can make sure that we don't go
too far off the rails?
My argument is that it's both.
If we're actively inferring.
Blue,
any thoughts?
I don't know. How is active
investing used in each paper?
I just want to go like look like.
Like what is the drive home message?
I mean, maybe that's something that
we can leave for the dot to.
Wish the graphical abstract.
Right.
For all of these strings.
Well, it is hard to fish stuff
out of the abduction paper
due to like the lack of figures.
I had to, like, go find my own figures
for the pretty picture.
Okay, let's look at one layer deeper
at the
the three ways that they suggest that one
can be a non realist about markup
blankets.
It'd be a whole nother intersection map
with whereas non realist anti-religious
pro instrumentalist just we could do
political compasses all over the map
and there would be even second
level questions
about how things are defined
and what periods of times.
And you just it's all good.
And so we try to
follow these again.
I like Dean
the way that you've brought it back
to like navigating in this continuous
space between two ferns,
between two
at minimum.
And then that stays in a kind of dynamic
navigational setting.
It's then if you're the moth, that's
if you can't go too close to the lantern,
either lantern.
If you hit one, then you die.
So your flight stops there.
So that, I think,
puts a very
meaningful interpretive layer
because just like I mentioned,
the figures
help with interpretation
and shorter lists help.
Like there's three reasons
why I'm against this.
Here they are, one, two and three.
Those are important structures.
Yet also,
there's a reason that people don't
communicate through outlines
outside of certain situations.
Okay, say tangent, but what are
the three ways that they're suggesting?
One can be a non realist about markup
like it's
what meaning less semantic tools
this is
going to be I think very interesting
they do not hold semantic value,
interpretive value,
linguistic or otherwise
other than that constructed
by using them to understand
or predict behavior.
In the situation where the scientist is
studying the stop sign,
they could say
you have the statistical edge
for me
at mind is being used instrumentally
and there would be a valid stance,
but especially when we take this semiotic
view which is very similar to semantic
and they have similar seed,
but the semiotic this
with a stop sign and the actual stopping
and the social and action of stopping
and the development of the agent
that led to them
having that belief in that context.
That isn't just setting it up
in terms of merely propositional logic,
which we hinted towards in the DOT
zero and many,
many of the peers in the comments dot
org articles lay it out much deeper.
But abduction is not
a static
set of rules alone.
The generating selection cycle includes,
at the very least,
structured novelty
arising from internal, external
and everything in between,
and a continuous type
attention distribution
and strategy on attention and so on.
So it's a much richer
setting than potentially semantic,
which can mean in certain
settings symbolic, which is to say
the kind of symbolic logic
carried out by like a Turing machine,
which can still be extensive.
So even a generous interpretation
is still very
plausible.
But there's something different
about semiotics and the bio semiotics
that was mentioned in the other paper
that is not one in the same
as the researchers modeling of.
And that was also explored
well by Yellow Bromberg in the 2016
paper.
The Anticipating Brain
is Not a Scientist, which contrasted
a scientific analysis modality
with the cognitive system
as cognizant and distinguishing
cognitive science in a way from that
through ecological psychology. The
Yeah, I was just going to tag on to that.
I think in order for this to happen,
I think in theory it's easy to say
we don't place a waiting on our priors
by simply doing.
I remain objective
throughout all of this,
but I don't think that most of us,
even when we take that
really strict scientific stance,
are aware of the priorities
and the weights that we have.
Even subconsciously apply.
So again, I think I think you can say
there's no there's no value add to this.
I'm just I'm just I remove myself from it
and I'm just a passive observer of it.
But I'm not sure how
how long we remain passive
before we start applying weights
and values to what it is that we're
we're
analyzing especially in a situation,
especially in situational analyzes
that are personal
and the consequences fall back on.
So now if you're simply watching
something and there is no consequence
upon you as the observer,
maybe that's easier to do.
But if you get to a place where
the scientist part of the experiment,
wow, show me how that
that switch gets turned off
and you don't place
a waiting on something.
Very powerful and true.
And in many ways,
implicitly and explicitly,
the kind of messaging sometimes
that I see in the information environment
is about getting people
to update their priors, to believe
that they're included in a larger,
which is an absolutely valid
communication and perspective
and the how of the path
and the homeostasis
and the multilevel system
and the critical path it has to follow,
including reflexivity
and narrative and anticipation.
And this bottom up, top down aspect,
it's that is social and action.
Like people can argue
that there's different social structures
and different settings
and it doesn't have to be a top bottom.
It doesn't have to be any specific
metaphor or cycle psychoanalytic
like lens, basically.
But the one shortcut
to collapsing all of that complexity
into a data point,
the this one trick is to approach it
like an experiment
because that is
what the experiment is in a way
it is about finding a manifold
where it's like
this tube has this strand of DNA
and this set of things,
and then that allows the
the paint on the wall
and all these other factors of the true
context
to be isolated from.
That's
kind of like the partial information
encapsulation
or just any other type of system.
And then potentially
we see like with Quantum.
Yes, some persistent anomalies
that suggested
things were not always as they seemed.
However, the real case
study is not the quantum mechanics,
but it's the Bayesian mechanics.
With the psychological study
and the neuroimaging study
and the behavioral study by all kinds of
people in all social and action settings.
And that really does point towards
some of the deeper
implications of interaction is
formal modeling of social
and cognitive systems.
One could
step out of that real life
and enter into another
and and situate themself
from like a third person perspective
and look back onto this single path plane
and see that as an experimenter.
And that is in many ways
associated with metacognition.
However, can that observer
claim realism versus instrumental ism?
What where people
speaking in terms of that view,
I don't know.
Just bringing up
that sort of like, are you,
where are you?
And that really relates
to the self-concept of Blue brought up
and like the kind of
situating this with the self-concept
and then realist instrumentalist.
But let's move on through these points.
Second reason why one could be a non
realist of America blankets.
One could merely
view them as valuable fictions.
Yes. Okay.
That allow abstracting
certain features of phenomena.
But a valuable fiction
one could ask
are all of the generated interpretation?
Is fictions valuable or not?
Or so does saying it's a fiction
and saying everything is a fiction
is that
in what ways
is that instrumental or in
what ways is that realists
making a real claim
that that is the stuff
which all things are, though
it's not of the stuff
that potentially somebody was taught
about atoms in a certain classroom.
So the persistent divergence
can some to think that one of those
is scientifically grounded
and another is metaphysically grounded
and or open to preference, faith or other
perhaps preferences
and concerns entering that discussion.
And then
the third one is,
you could be a non realist
about moral blankets
because just because it's
the success
of the use of the moral blanket
justifies, the acceptance
of the epistemic value of the model
without necessarily
making ontological claims,
in other words,
just because the physical model
is fitting well doesn't
mean it's really an AP cycle.
Just because the circular orbit models
fitting well.
How well?
99% until somebody comes along and goes
99.9 with a
totally different model structure.
So it's kind of like saying how
how sure could you be
about a realist interpretation
of the structure of the model
when as part of one's commitment
to the scientific,
they might leave the door open
to some future model
with higher explanatory
predictive power design and control, etc.
Then.
Yeah, that's
and I don't know where it is in the
we actually had it
because I was looking at the slides
from the 47 zero this morning
and there's a there's a part that's
highlighted in the other paper, the talks
where Peirce says, leave the door open.
That's what addiction is about.
It's simply the door is ajar.
You don't have the certainty,
but you have enough of you have enough
information to make
a hypothesis,
not an explanation to best or not
something rather to best explanation.
But you can
now you now have something to move off
to to leverage off.
And that's
because the door was left open.
So again, you can come at it from
you can come at this conclusion
that the third one,
the success of the Markoff blanket
through the instrumentalist lens.
But there's people on the realist side
that are saying the same thing.
The more open, the more likely
it is that you'll actually
get to the specifics sooner.
Here's a fun at example analogy
to kind of bring it back to Stephen's
earlier request.
There's a faster is slower
or slower is faster.
One can just imagine both ways.
But the empirical finding in ants
is that during certain escape
evacuation situations like
leaving a room
where alarm pheromone has been spread,
that when there's like
a constriction in the exits.
So the morphology of the nest
that they've constructed
when there's a constriction
that situation in car traffic
jams and in people
crowd situations can be very deadly
and that can be associated
with like a crush situation
or a liquid too solid, like jammed in
and then a fracture
which can have all kinds of issues
on the center of where it happens.
Whereas in the ants they slowed down
their individual movements.
So it wasn't like some orderly queue.
Everybody get in line and now we're going
to wait for number so-and-so be called.
This was like
their response in the situation
to the bio semiotics
and the niche construction of escape.
Right.
Was a slower is faster response
such that yes
their morphology as ness mates helps them
like by having legs that are wide out.
They're physically insulating.
So it's not to say that
that is the single thing for a human
to semantically keep in mind
in a physical escape setting.
But active inference lets us pull back
to those different settings
and at the ants
and their view from the inside the end of
so meiosis like the pheromones perception
in the neurobiology of the nest mate.
And then there's the exothermic
with the scientist,
and then there are
instruments in play. DIN
So you're not thinking through
amped minds that would be to
M instead of teaching more.
However, there is a sense
that there is
there is a hive mind at work,
even though you cannot necessarily
share that hot hive mind.
There is no blending,
there is an autonomy.
And there is a sense
that if if I am a believer
in the top down version, which
is enabled by an activism,
if I'm a believer in that,
I can also understand without thinking
through the mind of a realist,
what that realist
perspective is.
So you're not weird?
I would say that what Thomas and Inez
wrote
from that, from a logical standpoint
makes a lot of sense,
but that doesn't disqualify from my
my thinking and, this other way
of thinking from coexisting
and and and having
I don't think I don't know the answer.
Watching Daniel or not, maybe they are.
I mean, maybe there's another narrative
that Daniel will share with us about
when the ants became aware of him.
But I'll just tell you a quick story.
I feed Magpie.
I think Corbett's
and what the of realized is it's me
because they're very quick
to recognize faces
and what they do is they return the favor
I get I get little little
I get bones
from from from dead things
that they've eaten.
I get the bones
set on the same rock that I place the
the dog food on because they love this
this fish flavor, dog food.
They actually return things
and contribute back
because they want me to continue
that cycle.
So I don't know if ants do that, but
I do know I do know that other species,
whether they would describe it
as knowing my mind,
certainly want to influence my behavior
from a strategy standpoint.
Awesome lot of points there.
So that's in contrast with a framework
like Panpsychism
or like the absence of psych ism.
So just totally putting aside
many of those questions
you describe like a pan
intentional stance ism, a pan strategic
AM that allows for complex
hollow violence, blue's microbiome
as well as the human dog
supply chain Crow setting,
allowing
for those to exist and be modeled
by like decision making and control
theory, game theory, etc.
because of the pragmatism of the game.
It is like a doorway
into considering all these situations
as something to play, some games
to signal through, some games to win
in this way or to have this outcome.
So that's pretty interesting. Then
there's thinking through other species,
that's a very interesting idea
and be cool to design experiences
like games or art
that could allow
for different kinds of communication.
And then on the point in the objective
paper about the economy of science,
which we can return to that discussion
of Pearson's concept,
it's like thinking
through reviewers minds.
And so just seeing also facets
or thinking through my chess opponent's
mind.
It's not a total emulation
but note, but being able
to generate interfaces,
affordances, policies.
There's so much in a partial information
situation that the entity has generate
and the generation
scope means that there has to be
a strong selection mechanism too.
And those are the cycles of
temporal objective logic
which breaks us out of the inductive
deductive, static, conceptual
dialectic.
And this brings pragmatism, action,
ecological psychology and so on.
So it's really fascinating
to see what is flowing
within that space of formal models
of perception, cognition and action,
which are thousands of years old.
And it will be important to understand
so many of these different threads
because they're not all quantitative.
And the abductor of paper and the social
and active paper are demonstrating
two of the most important areas
where that's the case.
Then.
Yeah, I just want to real quick on that.
So it wouldn't matter if I decided that
I wanted to do a situational analysis
and based that on the very real gifting,
gifting size going on,
or at least I'm interpreting it
as a gifting exercise,
that would be one approach
that I could take.
The other approach I could take
would be a very instrumentalist one
in terms of token exchange.
Either one of those things
would work, putting them together
like might
be even more addictive.
I'm not sure.
I don't think it would be confusing.
I think it would just
provide two lenses on the same
on the same process.
Looking at
I have to lead on that as is figure
two and three.
So here is a perspective
on social construction
that they're pulling from non in activist
or non active inference perspectives.
The difference with Figure
three is the social action, and figure
two under the active inference
framework is the coupling.
And so there doesn't seem like
there be even one kind of thing
that would be captured by this gray box
in the middle of Figure three.
So play it safe.
Take an instrumentalist perspective
on this gray box.
It's one
very important node in interpretation
and then pass that through the tubes
to the objective reviewer
who looks at it and says yes.
And the social actors are engaging
in objective logic.
My background in Peirce suggests
that abduction,
primacy of the generation selection
and the time dynamics
and the flow of action
with the environment
from Pearce's work abduction
can be interpreted
in a realist framework.
So this can be held instrumentally
with this
view, with this I
and one can then ask
whether the abduction
that you're modeling it
doing objective logic
may even be able
to hold an instrumental stance.
But Is it instrumental
for the social actor
for the end of semiotics
instead of from the Exo
Symbiosis Blue?
So you kind of took the words
right out of my mouth there.
Good job.
So, like, is this gray box,
this sociocultural meanings, model
based reasoning,
like can those be subsumed under
CMOs?
Are you asking can it be a filter?
Like is excessive meiosis
like the imputation of such sociocultural
meanings and model based reasoning
is that extra symbiosis.
From the definitions
that I've seen in the usages I've seen it
XO means from the outside and means
insight in general in scientific words.
So meiosis is the meaning
construction process.
So exo
symbiosis is a view from the outside.
For example,
looking at that stop sign situation
unfolds, looking at that aunt pheromones
situation unfold.
Whereas the end dose of meiosis,
the interpretive semiotic process
by which something comes
to have an internal meaning,
which then could be asked
whether it's in a symbolic or a cognitive
or an intentioned way
and all these different aspects.
But I hope that that's an accurate
distinction.
You actually are you are you trying
to make this simple for my little brain?
Are you asking whether not a person
can take a third person perspective?
So I'm just trying to understand, like
the symbiosis is very clear to me, but
but like this exo symbiosis,
like when I like look it up, right?
Right. Like so,
Anderson,
meiosis is like the signal transmission
into the interior
that's like and those symbiosis like the
right like the interpretation of science
into the inside.
But like this exo
symbiosis is like between
organisms, like the silent
and signal transmission
between organisms of the same species
or of different species, like,
for example, the thermal.
Like that's what I read as exo symbiosis.
So when you look at that figure
three like
is that not exo symbiosis?
I mean it looks model representation
and what was the other thing in there?
So looking for the.
Here's
a fun view I think on the exo
so yes I think we're in agreement here
and the symbiosis is like the signaling
within the organism
or the view from the inside.
But that right there is the heart of also
the boundary as a physical versus
boundary as a functional. So
there's a whole
complexity with bio semiotics,
which is usually I think why people talk
about the bio semiotics
and just recognize the complexity
rather than take a stance
too early on that partitioning.
But then this one is the axis
and like perspective
constructing messages
to alleged extraterrestrials.
So if we look who.
Are the others,
who are the authors of that paper.
They're listed here. Douglas A coach.
But yeah.
Let's
well so
so just this like sociocultural
meaning imputation
and like in the mean paper
that Daniel and I
just put out and in
with RJ and Rachel
the semiotic representation
is culturally like relative.
I mean, like, there's no a stop sign
that isn't going to be a stop sign
to like someone in like the aboriginal
like very like native primitive
like lifestyle, right.
And so
the this exo exo
semiotic is like a transmission
between organisms of the same species,
but like also like the same culture
I would say.
Because like how do you you can't like
and even I don't know if that's true.
And pheromones, like if segments of
different species mean different things,
like the same pheromones
can have more than one meaning.
Is that also true or the same,
like kind of molecular compounds.
I mean,
I think we probably don't know enough.
I think I think I understand
what you're asking now.
Is there
is there an assumed sense that there
they're some some type of form
of entanglement has to be present
for any of that
to make sense to make sense
implies that something has existed
that didn't maybe exist
in the in that in the distant past.
It wouldn't exist in a different context.
So so that's
why the socio cultural meanings like,
like I think of that as like exo exo
some exists.
Like you.
I mean kind of goes
without saying that there's just
different
closeness is along different axis
like people
who are speaking the same language
but different vocabularies or
you know, the situation matter
so much the body language
then, the more distal or different
the cognitive structure is
relative to what it becomes
harder to, quote,
put yourself in their shoes
and so on.
And I feel like that's a
question with the multi scale system
phenomena is
whether they're dissipative
or persistence,
diverse intelligences, understanding
what the water we swim in
is cognitively and linguistically
because the water we swim in,
some of it is going to be the signal
or something else.
It could be the influence signal,
like the B matrix in active influencing
causal relationships in the world
as part of the water you swim in.
It also could be like modifications
through stigma, e.g.
niche modification,
like your physical influences,
which might be the water you swim
in, in the sense you don't notice them.
Like many things that come out of and
through us, we don't direct awareness of.
So they're like the paint on the walls
in that PCR experiment.
It's amplifying the DNA because
it's the parts that, whether we like it
or not, they get condensed down
to a dot or a path
and then that becomes, ah, like sense
making from local partial information,
as if a lot of the invisible part
we could just disregard.
And we do cognitively like we talked
about like the exhaust heat with Chris
Fields in quantum like you have to burn
information to pay attention
and and you have to pay attention
to deal with a real complex niche.
So there's a lot of tensions
in that path and
especially with
this dyad
and I'm sure so much other related work.
But with this dyad
and I think with the lens that Dean,
you helped approach it to with
it is putting some of those
threads into a different light,
and especially for those who
in this semiotic way
add some Bayesian surprise,
some cognitive state updating
from any number of different things.
That's like proof of concept
social in action,
but not in a corroded
or in a performance art.
Although who would say
it's not performance art but still way
that brings the realism into the social
through the formal
and doors.
Dean And then blue.
I think, I think I see
both of these papers as pillars.
I see them as really stabilizing
for different reasons.
And I would rather stand
on both of my feet
and have something stable under
both of them than try to stand on one
or both these standing on one cylinder.
Because I find that I find that
just based on my more and more difficult.
But as
as we tried to
take up this new season of live streams
and bringing two things together
that felt like a frontier moment.
And I think that one of the things that
I hope we have conveyed is that
looking at two things
at once is by nature
more complicated,
not necessarily complex.
The complexity exists
in each of the papers.
But two, to look at two things
at once is more complicated
and therefore is more fraught
with the error of the trial and error
relationship.
I'm not saying that
we made it much mistakes, but I think
the first
the first rule of generation is
you won't get it right
right away.
You will have to again
have that temporal commitment
in order to be able to get
wherever the heck you think you're going.
And I didn't really know where this
was going to go other than
I wonder
what happens if
we don't narrow our regime of attention
and necessarily know we were widening it.
But I did know at some point
we might get the authors
coming on and asking us, asking us
why these two.
I don't think it has to necessarily
be these two papers.
It's just that both of these papers
create and create a nice symphony, right?
So it could be any set of papers.
It takes a chocolatier
or a wine connoisseur
to really make the pairing special.
Yet there's other situations
where any pairing can be
potentially fruitful and insightful.
Like, sometimes I think about that
in a community context.
Like you're always going to share between
zero and one context, and wherever
you are on that continuum, the parts
where you're sharing is awesome.
In the parts where you're different.
We can also respect as great
or the overlap between two papers.
Well, the word used was opposite or
it was like contrary in some other way.
Okay. And then with a stance.
So then I thought of
the kind of like games where people have
to stand on a single pole
in a, in a
tropical, beautiful location
and try not to fall.
So I thought when you have both feet,
like you said on one position
narrow
then Buffetts of wind
are assaults on your equilibrium
steady state,
especially when it's like
which one of these one person
is going to be a professor
just as an example.
So why not resist
and return to a fixed mode?
Because that's like sort of the mode
seeking that we heard about
in some of Dalton
and Maxwell's recent work.
The fixed mode is the center of gravity.
And then another way
that you describe with I kind of having
like a nonzero divergence
and the space between
is like in basketball
the triple threat stance
because you could dribble
or pass or shoot
by like going for the basket.
And yeah, that's a different stance.
And it's also in a field of affordances.
So it's not just
that they're in a different position.
Like the feet here are not much
wider than the feet here,
but this is
the invest
again mood, as Peirce would have
maybe alluded to it, that in a context
with an action, ecological psychology,
all of that in a context
with an instrument and a game
and something outside
the game that supported the game.
All those levels
are in the triple threat.
But how did I get here?
Why am I on the green one
is a limited context and
I still think that.
Yes, it's still highly skilled.
Nobody's questioning how how much energy
is being poured into doing that.
And that's that's hard work.
And there's a huge reward for doing it
well.
And there's many.
And so I totally agree.
And even intend that people
could have trained a lot for this one.
This could be someone who doesn't
play basketball.
And so that's why it has to be
a little dynamic and situational, but
just seeing them as kind of like
extreme modes of paper interpretation
in an extended paper
interpretive metaphor,
one could see
different modes of receiving
some meiosis
from literature or discourse.
And then what is the role
of participation
and feedback.
And then that multi-agent setting
that we mentioned,
I hope that's not too random
in our last.
Yeah blue go for it.
So one like pairing of papers
that I would have liked to have done
is this objective reasoning paper
with the Chris Fields quantum paper,
the one from the 40
like because I was just reminded of it so
much as I was reading through the paper
and just like learning about objective
reasoning and what does that look like
and how like we, you know, in objective
you don't have complete information.
It's like partially observable.
And so like
you just make your best prediction
from like a partial observation.
And it made me think of like the quantum
reference frames
where you don't like it, like you can't
get full overlap with someone else's
quantum preference frame.
Like, like it's not
like even with perfect learning,
there's still going to be some noise
or some overlap between the quantum
reference or some incongruence. The
quantum reference frames, some area
that's not overlapping.
So, so I don't know,
I just those two things
that's like one pairing
that I would have liked to see.
That's that's really interesting.
Like as alluded to earlier, the quantum
broke the glass
on the reflexivity question
in philosophy of science.
I hope that's not to overstated to say
and it wasn't
the only piece in the building
or the weakening of the glass,
but the earlier mentioned persists.
An anomaly regarding experimental context
expanded the scope of certain questions
in science
beyond discourse
in certain cultural circles
during the last like 500 years
that Stephen alluded to parts of
so quantum is where
abductee of temporal relationality
it's there when you see it now,
it's not proto active particle of the
electron or just a pebble.
This wouldn't be happening.
Or if the electron were a pebble
that were bigger,
this wouldn't be happening.
But would it not be
or would it not be happening
because we could measure it better?
All of those questions about points
and particles and waves
under Bayesian mechanics
as a mechanics for cognitive
particles, the reflexivity
now can flow in
not just from electron scale,
but I feel like there are multiple
contact surfaces with reflexivity
at the semiotic
narrative ecological.
The real scales
outside of the experiment.
And I think that is what partially
speaks to
the way that we entered this dot
one discussion.
So in our last
five or 10 minutes, what would we like to
have or note
talked to just to the authors
if they listened to this in the time
between or not?
We're looking forward
to talking to anybody who wants to,
whether it's for the DOT
to or any point in the future.
There's always a dot three avoidance.
So we hope to continue this discussion
with those who have authored
and those who have not not yet authored,
because there's so much
to build on, on on this vector.
So both of you don't feel free
to as long as you would like,
just mention any points
that you want to discuss for next week.
Dean had brought up earlier.
Like where?
Where is active in France?
Is it is it
the basis is it like resting on top of
is there some kind of duality there?
I think that's something
that I would like to kind of look back
at each paper and and figure out,
like where I where, I want to put
active inference in that pillar
or on that pillar.
Or is it the pillar?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Are we going to be able to go with
our active inference colored highlighter
and say okay these two words yet
or you know this clause.
Yep, this paragraph
with this paper or
this interaction of the paper, this tool
developed by the paper,
where would one be to highlight
how I saw the paper?
And I know
Stephen would completely agree with you.
Can I just get you to put behind where
in brackets when is active inference?
Because
again, I think that matters so much
about inductive logic and rest reduction.
The other thing is, is that I,
I hope that that lose
thinking about well, what,
what if we pulled other papers
and entangled them.
What what might that.
I hope that's an opening.
I will say this
it takes incredible
amount of preparation.
If all two papers together
and not do the proper respect
for the amount of work that the authors,
the originators of that work have done.
So whatever the whatever the preparation
is in terms of quantifying it
for a single paper to it justice,
it's many multiples of that
to two papers.
But I think if we are going to be active
and first
not just subject matter
experts on activity trends,
that that exercise is difficult
and is time consuming as it is.
It literally,
literally changes that game
because we talked about the game here
quite a bit today, which again,
I didn't think that was going to come up,
but thank goodness, did
because it's not oppositional.
The game can be
everybody gets in the canoe
and works together
to arrive at Hawaiian Islands.
That can literally,
literally be the game.
Right?
It doesn't have to be a competition.
It's not a race.
It's do we survive
given the limited amount
of information that we need to glean here
as as as important to our are our
we are ability to continue on.
I think that's
what being an active employer is.
That's where we shift
from a subject matter expert
to a prediction matter expert.
Actually transitions.
So I want to thank people again for
what feels like hanging yourself
out there in a real risky way
because it is risky if that's
what it is.
Thanks again. There's so much to say.
I hope that it's an honor
and a privilege to be in epistemic spaces
and have one's
homeostatic variables secured.
So that opens up an amazing
space and approach.
The temporal aspect of abduction
sounds so great to return to
because I think another
one of those points of contact
communication is the dynamic.
What were the only formal isms
in either paper in terms
of like equations
and mathematical symbols?
It was three representations
of dynamical systems
of happily
to invent s to connect and ground
a contact point
from where they were taking a stance and
and a skilled performance into the
mathematical symbolic scientific.
Someone says this paper
is a philosophy paper.
Yes, but it has equations.
So that is going to come
to be something different.
And then
you start reading a paper,
change the game.
But reading multiple papers
changes the game and it is in a way true.
It is more
rides to keep in mind because
at least under some norms
and preferences for paper discussions
like personally I prefer
and find myself at home
when people don't extensively speak
from what a person thought
and take the end semiotic perspective
from them or from like a whole culture
which seems implausible to me,
but situates the semiotics of themself
in relationship
with a non-trivial and a symbiosis.
And where do those two threads meet?
The blanket, which is in
potentially its most elegant course
screening
represented by the gray box here.
And why would we want to delimit
or even grip?
Maybe the gripper that we
have at this point are like
car pliers
and this is something very different
and or something active.
So at this or any point in time.
It seems absolutely valid
to look at the structure of Figure
two and three and hold so many stances
at once or in rapid navigation.
So wow, what a fun discussion.
Thanks,
Steven, for joining and Blue and Dean.
And we will look forward to some
interesting times in the data and beyond.
So peace out.